Drizzy Drakes
son
what does that mean Drake's son Adonis
steals the spotlight in the latest
episode of Barstool Sports Sunday
conversation with Caleb Presley kind of
excited in the clip shared Sunday the
five-year-old gives some insight into
his famous dad's parenting skills can
you read no I can't do you think if you
had a better dad you would be able to
read
this is my battle dad
do you think if he did a better job with
you at home that you'd be able to read
yeah and that's a funny dad also he does
a lot of jokes of course the whole thing
isn't good fun and Adonis couldn't be
cuter there's a lot of friends on me
that are really nice to me what do they
say when they're being when they're
being nice
they say I like because you're being
nice to me what do they say when they're
being mean they say I don't like you
because you're being mean to me and were
you I wasn't mean to them are you sure
I'm sure the way you said that made me
think that you were being maybe being
mean no I'm not Drake shares Adonis who
was born in 2017 with Sophie brousseau a
retired adult film star who now works as
an artist the rappers never shy to post
his little guy especially when it comes
to his impressive basketball skills
back in October the rapper celebrated
adonis's fifth B-day with a superhero
themed bash I wasn't hiding my kid from
the world I was hot in the world for my
kid Drake confirmed he had a son in June
2018 on his album scorpion a month after
Pusha T released the story of adidon a
diss track that suggested Drake may have
fathered a child Drake first shared
photos of his son on social media in
March 2020 and in May 2021 Drake brought
his son to the Billboard Music Awards he
even let him hold his trophy as he
accepted the award for artists of the
decade now Drake says being a dad is
everything what's the best thing to bet
on
uh
fatherhood
you bet on fire
you can always that you bet on
fatherhood a lot I just meant it more
like an encouraging like you can always
bet on fatherhood
right I've never heard that before I
just met like
for for all the people out there you can
always BET our products but let me send
you off with an extra dose of sweetness
courtesy Adonis well
is there anything you want to say or
anything like that bye bye even outside
of babai is there any one more thing you
forgot to say but you were about to say
it I forgot to say that I'm
a shooting star
[Music]